we have a huge hole in the public
finances we spend 407 billion pounds on
covid support and our debt now stands at
over 2 trillion pounds
and waiting lists will almost certainly
go up before they come down
kovid pushed out a great bow wave of
cases people did not or could not
seek help and that wave is now coming
back
a tide of anxiety washing into every a e
and every gp your hip replacement your
mother's surgery and this is the
priority of the british people
does anyone seriously imagine that we
should not now be raising the funding to
sort this out is that really the view of
responsible conservatives i can tell you
something margaret thatcher would not
have ignored the meteorite that has just
crashed through the public finances she
would have wagged her finger
and said more borrowing now
is just higher interest rates and even
higher taxes later
when this country was sick
our nhs
was the nurse
frontline care workers battled against a
new disease selflessly risking their
lives sacrificing their lives and
it is right that this party that has
looked after the nhs for most of its
history should be the one to rise to the
challenge 48 new hospitals 50 000 more
nurses 50 million more gp appointments
40 new diagnostic centers and fixing
those backlogs with real change because
the pandemic not only put colossal
pressure on the nhs it was a lightning
flash illumination of a problem we have
failed to address for decades
in 1948 this country created the
national health service but kept social
care local and though that made sense in
many ways generations
of older people have found themselves
lost in the gap
when coveted broke the 100 000 beds in
the nhs
and 30 000
occupied by people who could have been
cared for elsewhere whether at home or
in residential care
and we all know that this problem of
delayed discharge is one of the major
reasons why it takes too long to get the
hospital treatment that your family
desperately need and people worry that
they will be the one there they will be
the one in ten to suffer from the
potentially catastrophic cost of
dementia
wiping out everything they have and
preventing them from passing on anything
to their families
and we conservatives stand by those who
have shared our values
thrift and hard work
and who face total destitution in this
brutal lottery of old age in which
treatment for cancer is funded by the
state and care for alzheimer's is not or
only partly
and to fix these twin problems of the
nhs and social care we aren't just going
to siphon billions of new taxes into
crucial services without improving
important performance we will use new
technology so that there is a single set
of electronic records as patients pass
between health and social care improving
care and ensuring that cash goes to the
front line and not on needless
bureaucracy